since the beginning of time the
Warlord's have brought suffering and
death to our world but one thousand
monks sacrifice themselves to empower a
chosen one to stop them I've been
looking for you Kai you have the power
of the monks their strength flows
through you the faces we protect you
what's this got to do with me you're
here because san francisco's were at the
path of the wool warlords converged I'm
just a share no Chi you are the war
assassin
the walls house is a threat to me which
means is a threat to you and to
Chinatown find the assassin who can't
just kill the head of the triad
he's your father I have to try
we have to help kind save the world
whatever happens I got your back her
family my brother's dollar I am we are
down to ten you heard the woman
chop-chop would you go bro till his last
classroom on apace it's a nice ass ass
going to do whatever is necessary to
protect my pebble rock and if I have to
my own beloved son you ready are you
oh you I'm a chef I've seen this lose a
son it ain't hand it's some old ball
dude
oh whoa okay stop doing it
you
you